i was uh i was trying to find who said
this and i
i'm kind of bummed that i can't i don't
have it pulled up but i read it earlier
today and it was someone was just
responding to a long conversation on
twitter
and basically it was saying the left
just sees anyone on the right
that's not on the left as evil yep just
complete evil
and they can't even get along with them
because they're just evil
but someone who's not on the far left
can be friends can can tolerate the
people on the left because they're
they they don't think see them as evil
they see them as misinformed
right the right thing is a huge
difference the right thinks the left is
misguided the left thinks the right is
evil
character it's a big difference it's
really crazy how hateful some of my
friends have become it's just
just it's it's like watching uh an anger
machine
i can say the same thing tim it's it's
it's scary
it's sad there are people there they're
people that i used to really really
respect because they've always been very
progressive
but they've always been very socratic
trying to have conversations
and be open inviting and now they've
become rage-a-holics
they just want to scream just just
i don't know this is there's a viral
video a bunch of women stripping their
clothes off and screaming
and just groaning and screaming and
you know you know what i'm talking about
i i'm cringing because you know what
i've
watched it yes and there's pictures and
you're just like what is this
i'm 75 straighter what is why
you know what man every day i wake up
you know the first thing i think is
today is going to be a good day guess
what it is
because it's like the sun is shining you
know you know what i think when it's a
nice sunny day
oh it's a nice sunny day oh it's pretty
warm well i'll get all nice and sweaty
on that skate i love getting all sweaty
don't escape you know what i think when
it's raining
oh oh no i think i can't skate today no
nice nice rain i guess
i got to get a day off from skating i'll
chill out you know the flowers
the flowers will grow tomorrow the point
is
i don't i don't look at the rain as a
problem right when it's raining i'm like
oh cool finally a storm
and you're like look out the window and
you're like wow it's like what's your
world view
for me no matter what the weather is
like it's it's it's an awesome it's wow
you know hey these things happen i'm
alive i'm here i'm going to make the
best of it it's a good point but these
people are becoming
infected with a demoralized
demoralization mind virus
everything is awful everything is awful
it's too hot
it's so hot now it's raining and i'm wet
like you were talking about uh
if the if with floorbow like yeah
you they can't even be they're they're
mad at that they banned floorball from
we had someone brought it back right but
it's like yeah that's not even enough
it's like because they want to be angry
right so that if you try if even if you
try and find a solution they'll find
some way to be angry this is why they
attack themselves and each other
that's true that's why i tell people
there is
no staying safe they're you know you
know what's really funny
imagine like imagine this scenario
zombies are rampaging through the city
eating everybody's brains yeah
and someone's like well as long as i
don't yell at the zombies they won't eat
my brains
like but they're eating everyone's
brains they're not going to ignore you
for any reason
in their logic they'll be angry they're
condoning people eating brains
it reminds me you know what it reminds
me of it's like a shawn of the dead
how they cover themselves in oh yeah
guts yeah and then they start going oh
like
how do the zombies know it's so
hilarious
but like is that the goal is that what
people are doing maybe
so the cdc i covered the story earlier
today
has 1200 employees signed a letter
demanding that they declare racism to be
a public health crisis
i don't know what that means but you
mean to tell me the cdc has 1
200 people who all agreed with that yeah
no i think a good portion are shawn of
the dead people
rubbing rubbing the guts all over them
and going i'm a zombie too
don't bite me look how woke i am i don't
have a brain i'll sign it
i bet it was one or two people they're
like will you sign our pledge
sure sign now please don't don't attack
me
and now you end up with 1200 signatures
yeah these are
it's like somebody tweeted this to me
saying i've got a family and i've got to
keep them safe and i'm like
but you were literally not doing that
like get like
imagine this imagine this you're with
your family in
in you know in the middle of the forest
in a tent and a bear comes up
and starts shredding the tents and just
mauling everybody and you're like
calm down if we just be nice to the bear
it won't maul us efforts finished
mauling everyone else
yeah i'm keeping my family safe by not
by not doing anything to deal with the
fact a bear is killing people
right and the bear mauls everybody and
then you're like oh no how could this
have happened
it reminds me that the the the um that
meme which one
the the andre what's his face mean you
know that meme where he shoots the guy
on the couch
oh yeah um yeah he's like how dare you
make me do this no well there's like i
mean there's a million different people
how could they do this yeah how could
they do this yeah
i'm like have you heard of unwoke though
the website the hiring website yep
yeah yeah so for companies that don't
want to deal with
people who are woke it's anonymous you
get a job at i mean well yeah you're
gonna pull it up okay it is yeah so
here we go higher thinkers not activists
hire courageous free thinking and
freedom loving individuals
not ideologues who own whose only agenda
is to weaponize your brand
and business to further a radical cause
check this out look at this
that is some serious stuff right there
this is interesting look at all these
people
and there's a lot who have listed their
skills
their resumes you've got video editors
you've got business operations
leadership uh web developers 120 000 a
year
serious jobs here yeah these are legit
like careers but you got recent college
grad with certain knowledge as a manager
yeah and then you can also find
work so that's those are those are those
are employees here's employers
these are people looking for jobs we're
looking for people who can do these
things
and we don't want woke people right how
amazing
yeah this is this is uh carlin carlin uh
borsenko
posted this up this morning i was like
that is that is dope
yeah like that's what we need this this
is more people are like you know what
we've had enough
we're not gonna hire these people you
can't you're not welcome here anymore
because needless to say racism
isn't prevalent like you're saying it is
well it seems like they're trying to
head it off at the pass
like they're trying to stop it before it
even starts don't even bring it into
your company
right which i think is great it's a good
idea oh okay the companies are you made
right right right right yeah right
i i told you about when i worked for the
nonprofits
i did a twitter thread about it but i'll
give you i'll give the quick version
okay
we i used to do street canvassing other
people would walk right outside and be
like yo
hey come talk to me i'm going to save
the bears or whatever yeah and then you
fill out the form and you give your
credit card and
now you're a member for life not really
but you sign up for a monthly donation
i used to do that it's a very very
taxing job because
for the average person everyone rejects
you yeah i did tell marketing for a
while
they so there's there's a lot to talk
about in this field
for me and my friends we were we were
man we were masters
we didn't waste our time targeting
people we knew didn't want to talk to us
right so we didn't deal with this but
most people get rejected 9 out of 10
times
and that level of rejection starts
demoralizing people who who don't have
the mental fortitude to handle that kind
of rejection non-stop get away from me
no
i'm sorry not today oh don't talk to me
yeah it was tough
telemarketing so were you doing it on
the phone no street oh straight
walking yeah all right so what happens
is
eventually someone gets totally
demoralized
frustrated angry no matter what i do
it's impossible
then they look over at me and i'm
sitting there with like my eyes half
glazed over and shut and i go
you over there come here and then go
what's up mike sign this out give me a
credit card and they do and it's like
how did he do that
so now they're watching other people do
it they can't figure it out they get
really really really angry hey you
yeah yeah yeah come over here jump in
the pool no but but this is coming up in
the pool this is part of the
this is part of the problem when you
would have people who'd be like hi there
would you like to talk about the
environment
no i wouldn't do i wouldn't do that
right i'd be like yo yo what up
and they'd be like calm me i'm like yeah
come here come come here like why what's
up check us out here take that they take
it i'm like read it i'm like okay
and it's just just like boom just talk
about it that doesn't work for you
but so what happens is people get
frustrated it's like playing a video
game
where no matter what you do you keep
losing you get really angry they go back
to the office
and they're fuming and they'll be
sitting next to someone and they'll go
this job is
impossible it's so dumb i'm sick of it
these people everyone is mean
everyone is awful all the time i hate
everyone then that negativity spreads to
someone else
and they start getting anxiety then they
go out they hyper focus on the
negative and the office starts breeding
negativity yeah you know the directors
of the offices would do and that happens
fire everybody fire every single person
they'd fire everyone no matter what even
even the people who are good at it you
know why
they want to make sure no one remembered
no one remembered the demoralization
so it's very maoist isn't it absolutely
yup a little bit so when the new office
comes in
everyone's like they'd be like we're
just relaunching our new season campaign
and everybody always does really well
yeah everything's the best
but then as soon as the the they would
try and catch it fast
yeah so they would do debriefs you'd
come back and if they're like how are
you feeling what do you think and as
soon as you start saying things like
i don't know it's just so hard they'd be
like okay well you know we'll talk to
you and they call you
don't come back because they don't want
you to spread that pessimism that
negativity
and that's but that's that's that's
ripping through the country right now
people who just wake up every morning
and they go
i'm angry i hate everything and i
want to hate more and i wake up and i'm
like life's
great what trick do i want to do today i
get about an hour to skate
i really want to try blunt backside 180.
oh man i'm so excited
once i get done with work i get to go
out there and try that trick for the day
i just want that one run man
yeah adam's been trying a pretty a
pretty a pretty beefy run
trying to get it you'll get it i'll get
it so when i wake up
i'm thinking like i got my plans for the
day i got to do my work man you know
and the reward is sitting there waiting
to get a good skate session get all
sweaty
oh it's 90 degrees out it's like wow
it's hot i'm like great i'll get sweaty
it's good it's healthy
you're dripping yeah dude just just whoa
my shirt's all durants it feels good
everything can be a good thing like
you've got you've got this mangled
twisted scar on your on your ankle yeah
from getting you know skateboard
whacking you i have multiple twisted
scars on my ankles now
but there's one in particular but we
joke about it it's quite large you keep
you you keep
like you posted a photo right yeah like
there's blood everywhere yeah
and you got a big ol smile on your face
you're like cool i'm gonna post a
picture of it
it's like actually no i didn't say that
you said i was like dude
yeah nah you gotta post a picture and
i'm like all right
but but there it is man positive mental
attitude it's true
you you you were your your ankle was
covered in blood yeah
you have every reason to be like ah i'm
so angry
instead you're just like i'm gonna i'll
post a picture all right and like
laughing about it and that's like when
whenever
whenever one of us gets hurt like we
have we don't get seriously hurt but
you'll be skating you'll fall down
one of us will be like you got to pay
your dues yeah it's like that's just
part of life you know
it's true these people don't have that
they're like i should could you imagine
a skateboarder whose mentality was i
shouldn't
have to get hurt ever that's not that
that doesn't exist in skateboarding no
it should be falling and skateboarding
should be banned
whoa that's what skateboarding is not
long for this world if that's the case
that's what i hear when they're like ban
hate speech well this is what i when i
when we were skating the other day
and i was like man this i love
skateboarding you know
i feel like everyone needs to at least
try it because there's something about
getting getting hurt
and and trying to it's not a competitive
sport
it you are facing only one person and
it's yourself
and when you're able to conquer yourself
and
learn something that's difficult that is
painful that
you can get bloody ankles and if you can
get past that and you land that trick
even if it's an aldi even if it's just
rolling forward that even just that
is is exciting is it's actually a really
funny thing like somehow
adam manages to hit the exact same spot
like a couple times
it's true it's like oh it's like it's
like winning you got to go buy a lottery
ticket
i told you i'm lucky it's like you think
i'm joking hitting you in the same
i'm lucky man i i have constant luck
and i am supremely blessed because of it
but you're
but this is funny too like of course i'm
lucky because it keeps hitting the same
spot
no but this is funny it's like your your
view of this injury is is that it's good
luck it's that you're a lucky person
it's true when you have every reason to
be angry about it instead it's it's a
funny thing that's that's how it is
and that's funny i think that's i think
what we're describing with all this is
healthy masculinity
okay enjoying the the the rye with a
smile on your face the good and the bad
all the things that come with life
that's a good point maybe not even
masculinity
i the reason i say that is because like
the idea of getting hurt
i think within reason getting hurt feels
good
and it's not so much that like you like
you like pain like you're a masochist or
something
it's it's it's annoying like you get you
get whacked in the shin and you and
you're like when you get angry yeah but
then you laugh and you're like hey man
you know that's the name of the game
that that proves you're playing these
are the risks that come with it
yeah and it's it for me when i get hurt
skating it reminds me of like
the point of skating that you are like
when i do a trick
that fear of trying the new trick is the
reward it's like overcoming this mental
and physical challenge
and when you sometimes get hurts when
you sometimes get hurt
it's reminding you that the the road
traveled
well it's reminding you of what makes
the game worth playing
exactly you're avoiding this yes you
don't want to get hurt
it might happen and when it does you're
like i got me behind me but when you
land that trick
you've got five seconds of like a
dopamine revelation yeah it's true and
then after that it never comes back
no that's not true well no no what i
mean you just have to keep doing
stronger and harder exactly
there was a there was a great essay i
read about skateboarding and they
described like
in very great detail someone doing a
really difficult trick down a massive
set of stairs okay
and it was like it was written like
adrian's at the top you know
a seven foot tall you know ten foot
long stair set his goal right now to
make the board spin 360 degrees
flipping and over end one time catching
it in midair
landing it and riding away and then it
goes into great detail it's like he
drops the board to his feet and then
finally when you get to the bottom of
the essay it's like
with the board now in the air his feet
firmly on it he lands and in that moment
he feels the greatest feeling of
accomplishment he will ever feel in his
life
that's awesome and three seconds later
it's gone yeah
and he wants it again mm-hmm and he
can't and and he's gonna get high again
he can't do the same thing to get that
feeling good
man that's a good point so it's like
it's it's all part of that challenge
if you don't have that in your life i
wonder i have to wonder i mean there's a
lot of people and i think
there's probably some correlation
between the willingness to fight take
risks
take challenges you know uh complete
challenges yeah and
wokeness and the sjws who are unwilling
and haven't they won't do this
they think everything should be bubble
wrapped
and they think all masculinity is toxic
and that
that couldn't be further from the truth
right
like there needs to be a balance in
society of both
it's it's you know it's toxic femininity
toxic masculinity is like basically
being purged out anyway
like you getting anywhere close to it
and they cancel you but there's nothing
stopping the left or or toxic femininity
femininity yeah you know there's another
thing too i was i was thinking about
this when it came to get what go broke
concept toxic diversity hmm i've never
heard that
no i was just thinking about it i
thought that's okay that's what i'm
gonna call it
so because because i think diversity is
a good thing yeah give you an example
different people from different parts of
the world with different perspectives
contributing to solving a big problem
like the international space station
a bunch of different nations coming
together and their different views
developments technology
research helps make the station work
that's absolutely true it's a great
example
tucker carlson has antifa on his show
where he debates them
diversity and thought oh definitely cool
i didn't know that's
interesting that's what diversity is
supposed to represent not just
skin color but perspective ideas that
reminds me of a conversation i was
having today with a friend of mine
he didn't want to watch that documentary
and i was like why what about it that
you don't want to watch
oh well i just i heard this and that and
a few other people are saying oh well oh
candace owens is in it
so i i know what she's all about so i'm
not gonna watch the documentary it's
like
so so you're admitting to me you're
refusing to just even
accept to view the opposing side
that and well no i'm not done one of the
friend that i was talking to
we we were talking for a while about it
and eventually
got to the point where he was like
you're right i'll go watch it
and i was like yes go watch it and tell
me please hit me up right when you're
done and call me we'll talk are these
people purported supporters of black
lives matter
uh some of them are and they refuse to
watch black voices speaking out that's
correct toxic diversity
good point yeah these are exactly so
when you see these like movies
where it's like you know diversity at
the expense of another group
that's toxic diversity yeah so like
we're gonna do a movie with a female
lead
and then that female all those all the
women in the movie are just talking
about how dumb men are toxic diversity
you want it sounds familiar terry john's
really familiar what how where do i know
that from
name name one of the movies blocking it
out
we did a review on it i was gonna say
ghostbusters oh ghostbusters okay that's
true yeah i was talking about uh
the birds of prey yeah same thing with
ghostbusters 2016 it was criticized
because they were trying to empower
women at the expense of men
right exactly whereas wonder woman
allows the characters to be strong good
or bad in their own right
exactly real diverse nailed it you look
at uh into the spider verse
miles morales main character awesome
mentored by an older
divorced kind of loser spiderman yeah
but he's a guy with flaws
that's true but he's also still a hero
who does help miles become
the spider-man he needs to be that
honestly no now that i've i i've saw it
and i love that movie it might be my
favorite
spider-man movie oh i i don't know i i i
think so i think so as well
100 yeah i do great i got to say i love
homecoming i'm not
i'm far from home oh yeah those those
ones are pretty good too yeah
mysterio was that was an aw i love that
that was great oh no i haven't seen that
one yet
you haven't seen far from home no dude
dude i got this but
look i got to see that i always love
referencing this static shock
i know yeah real diversity that's yeah
the story is great but then you get
birds of prey toxic diversity toxic yeah
and this is what they do when we when
whenever i think this is a
this is an important distinction in
toxic diversity because i think it
explains
uh what what really is that issue here
i've had conversations with progressives
where they're like
you just don't like you know you're you
know you just supporting racist or
whatever
trying to explain what authoritarian
social justice is
you know where people are cancelling you
know cancel culture and stuff like that
yeah
but when talking about get woke go broke
complaining about the gillette
commercial
right the gillette commercial it's not
because of diversity
it's toxic it's it's it's it's
belittling one group of people
showing a bunch of men and saying what
men do are bad men are bad man bad
that's all toxic agreed they
they could have done i know what they
used to do it used to be the best demand
could be
and it was like showing firefighters and
like heroes yeah but then they're like
nah let's let's drag and insult the guys
who buy our products
toxic represent the good and show a good
example of what people should be doing
boom
spiderman into the spider verse you had
you have the japanese
uh uh i don't know her name but she
kimiko i think maybe
she's got the spider mech oh yeah you've
got spiderman noir
you've got nicholas cage spider-man
right that's him i know nicholas cage
spider-man dude that was awesome i love
that
but nobody complained about that yeah
there was there were no i mean there
were some people for sure
was there i don't know i mean because
racists exist that's true but the
is overwhelmingly positive everybody
loves it yeah and then the other funny
thing too is like with the last of us
too
it's getting a lot of bad reviews and
it's funny when people are like
these men just don't like seeing strong
women and then people are like
the last of us uh has a a a an add-on
dlc okay nobody complained about that
the first one yeah
no so the first game has an addition
it's like an analogy yeah where you play
as ellie and another girl i guess i
don't know a lot about it
but then people reference a ton of games
with strong female leads and they're
like
gee i wonder why it is why no one's
complaining about these games that's a
good point
maybe there's something toxic about how
these games
go about their storytelling yep that you
won't accept
so i'll tell you what i'll tell you what
i'm about to do i will absolutely accept
this toxic masculinity
you know yeah well there is macho bros
who refuse to accept fault for anything
who think they're better than everyone
else they're egotists they're they're
bullies
and there's real masculinity the dude
who you know runs full speed to like
push a kid out of the way of a car
before the car hits him or the man that
that
caught that baby from the fire fire
yeah what a boss it's like yeah he ran
over and caught that baby like awesome
or how about a firefighter in general
runs into a burning building yeah with
the real risk to their life
life or the police officer who runs
towards the gunfire yep
real masculinity yeah toxic masculinity
is unearned
arrogant you know dominant behavior you
know you know i think you know i think
i think toxic masculinity is when you
cheat to be a man
good good call yeah that's a good point
whereas someone who's truly masculine
would you know like a tree a you know a
moderately sized tree is about to fall
down on a kid and he runs over and he
grabs it he's like
and he's like risking himself and he's
like trying to stop the tree from
crushing a kid yeah
superhero stuff like uh from game of
thrones it's like
the king that needs to to yell and
scream that he's the king
is no king at all toxic masculinity is
the guy who brags and lies
and pretends like he's better than
everyone else to assert his masculinity
versus the guy who keeps his mouth shut
and is just you know who just simply is
the king
yep yep yeah man and then there's toxic
femininity
it's it's it's toxicity
i think we need to call out toxic
diversity that's great i like that a lot
toxic diversity yeah it's really
it's solid we gotta toxic we gotta talk
about it
is when someone rags on white people
you know for the sake of like i'm not
racist and then they they do
what is that that mute white people
button on instagram right toxic
diversity
toxic blaming asians for their success
and saying that we should be allowed to
discriminate against them in schools
right toxic diversity exactly you are
not actually trying to help people solve
these problems and poverty
you are just being racist that's
toxicity
that's and what's this makes me think of
what i said yesterday we
people need to stop con confusing
holding people accountable for their
actions or lack of actions
with racism because it's not the same
thing right
it's toxic right people do bad things
they're like you can't criticize them
yeah exactly that's toxic diversity
you know and so that's that's what i
think is happening we've got uh
to to throw to jordan peterson i guess
we don't know where the line is
so our brands our institutions will not
draw a line and say that's too far
yep we know when the right goes too far
we know when men go too far
what about women literally i've heard
attempts at defining toxic femininity
from many people and they can't do it
well there's actually a rise of i'm
seeing this
and like amber amber heard for example
she she's it's probably the biggest case
of the opposite side of it
and and i'm seeing tweets that are
flowing around about how
you know men don't complain
they don't they don't uh because of
their masculinity
when they get abused they're more
inclined to go
i'm not gonna let this affect me or you
know
complain about it you know so it kind of
like gets swept under the rug like it
doesn't exist when it
clearly does i would define toxic
feminine femininity
as wrapping an entire room in bubble
wrap
putting your kids wrapping pillows
around their body banning all naughty
words
banning all hate speech banning all
rough housing
and then just like suspending them from
a series of elastic straps
so that an earthquake wouldn't hurt them
and they just don't move yes
it's like the most extreme version of
protecting someone possible you know
you know who i know this pisses off who
lydia
you know how i know i could tell i could
see no no i could see you're on the edge
of your seat
so it it takes me off tim's right about
wrapping people in bubble wrap but
there's a savage element
and it's not the kind of masculine
savagery it's not on the front lines
it's underneath it is sneaky
it is manipulative i really don't like
it
because i've seen it so so a feminine
savagery you mean yeah
is what you're saying yeah well it's
it's under the surface it's listen
and subliminal savagery that's i like
that
it's so i think about if you want to use
the word masculinity and
femininity what they're supposed to
represent the masculine
is going on in the hunt the feminine is
nurturing and caring and providing for
the family
both can be toxic the arrogant guy who
bullies people and pushes him around and
thinks he's better than everyone else is
toxic
the the mother that refuses to allow
their children to grow up and experience
the world
wraps them in bubble wrap and snow
applause everything is toxic
you are not helping the children survive
you're not helping anybody
yeah they're not preparing them for
real life yeah what it's really like out
there yeah
yeah it's not fair it's toxic to the
kids and then there's also of course the
manipulative
you know but you know why i don't i
don't necessarily equate that with
feminism
lying to steal resources is not
masculine or feminine i'm talking about
i'm talking about using your whiles
and using your brains to get what you
want i'm not talking about controlling
like means i'm saying i don't see that
as anything to do with
you don't think female or femininity
interesting no because men do it
you've got confident charismatic men who
sell snake oil that's true
you know they'll walk up and be like
this year this guy right here vote for
him
and he'll end racism so that's just that
just sounds like
toxic character
[Laughter]
yes where's my like button wait hold on
we gotta find that like button real fast
oh yes there we go my like button
oh i love my like button yes
okay thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you